[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich bin fast 28 jahre alt und informatik
trainerin für sehbehinderte im
beruflichen umfeld
ich mache die nächsten vier wochen ein
experiment zum thema selbst vermessung
dazu nutze ich apps und gadgets vor
allem in den bereichen fitness ernährung
und erholung und möchte so sehen ob und
wie ich mein leben damit optimieren kann
ich habe mich vor einigen monaten
verletzt und kommen jetzt gerade aus der
verletzungsphase raus darf jetzt also
wieder im sport starten
ich möchte in dreieinhalb wochen in
spartacus waren in sursee mitlaufen sind
um die sechseinhalb kilometer mit
minimum 20 hindernissen
da muss sich was tun und wenn ich mich
nicht optimiert dann schaffe ich das
nicht ich will meine excel liste aus um
meine ziele zu definieren und die dann
zu überprüfen und zwar würde ich gerne
versuchen minimum sieben stunden zu
schlafen das sich beim sport fitter wert
und ich möchte sechs kilo abnehmen messe
tue ich drei bereiche fitness ernährung
und erholung
das sind ja schon viele daten die ich
jetzt persönlich sammeln will
und ja da bin ich jetzt anschaue wie
kann ich das am besten da stelle ich
hätte am schluss auch gerne diagramme
weil es mir ein paar farblich zeigt wo
stehe ich was muss ich noch machen
und überhaupt auch zu wissen okay was
schaffe ich überhaupt es ist ganz klar
eine selbstreflexion und eine motivation
für mich und ich habe es gern
aufgeschrieben was ich mache was ich tun
muss ich habe gerne hilfe hilfe von den
apps
[Musik]
ich würde gern gewicht verlieren und
meine ausdauer steigern und daher an
trainingstagen 1700 kalorien und wenn
ich jetzt mal nichts mache oder weniger
dann auch weniger kalorien
ich koche ethnischer shooter ich stelle
meine leerung dahingehend um dass ich
weniger kohlenhydrate es ist eigentlich
was was jeder kennt aber was sich
besonderes machen möchte ist dass ich
auf getreide und milchprodukte und
komplett auf zucker verzichten will die
technik und vermessung hilft mir
eigentlich dabei so ein bisschen auch zu
sehen dass ich überhaupt in den
lebensmitteln drin ich habe jetzt gerade
meine ernährung shrek app geöffnet um
meine zutaten einzugeben und zu scannen
und sie hat mich jetzt auch schon
erinnert dass ich mein abendessen
eingeben soll also passt grad
ich kann das hier jetzt mal schauen ob
es gibt sollte ich hier unter die
handykamera dann wird mir das angezeigt
und kann ich dann entscheiden ist es
richtig und ich kann noch die portionen
aussuchen und es war jetzt in tales
boden und jetzt zb eine paprika die ist
hinterlegt also in der normalen größe
ich könnte jetzt auch abbiegen das wäre
noch besser und die würde ich dann
einzeln eingeben und so gibt es dann
eben das gericht insgesamt
und so weiß ganz genau wie viel kalorien
drin sind ohne damit ich mich darauf
verlassen muss was jetzt drauf steht
haye siri timer zehn minuten
[Musik]
meine ernährung umzustellen fällt mir in
gewisser weise schwer
ich würde lügen wenn ich sagen das alles
wie sie und ich glaube die ersten paar
tage ist gar nicht so schlimm weil er
ist die motivation noch sehr groß dass
wirklich durchzuziehen und zu machen
schlimm wird's dann erst wenn man
unterwegs ist und mehr tut sollte ich
eigentlich essen und alles was ich
bekomme zum beispiel beim bäcker darf
ich nicht essen weil kein getreide und
dann fällt einem schon schwer
ich komme aus einer verletzung genauer
habe ich mir vor vier wochen ein
außenband gerissen im fuß und davor
hatte ich schwere prellung und schwere
halswirbel prellung durch ein reitunfall
und jetzt ist heute das erste mal wo ich
wieder laufen gehen und bin jetzt
gespannt wie es läuft
ich checke meine zielsetzung im fitness
erstmal mit einer app und mit einem
gerät war es die ganzen parameter misst
das wäre es in dem fall meine uhr
gemessen wird mein herzschlag gemessen
wird welche strecke laufe ich mit gps
und meine pace das bedeutet wie schnell
bin ich überhaupt und daran würde ich
mich gern so ein bisschen messen meine
größte motivation ist natürlich
möglichst schnell ergebnisse zu sehen
und fit zu werden war kann immer sagen
jetzt bin ich besser geworden ich fühle
mich besser aber schlussendlich zählt
auch nur das was gemessen wurde
zwei kilometer dauert zwölf minuten 51
space von 622 also wie viel minuten
braucht für einen kilometer und sabrina
habe mich verbrannt
238 und meine herzfrequenz mal im
durchschnitt bei 177 noch ein bisschen
hoch max politisch bei mir so bei 185
das heißt dann kriege ich keine luft
mehr und er könnte noch ein bisschen
stabiler unten sei das erste mal auch
ein gut
ja ich hab jetzt noch ein bisschen was
anderen einfach zu schauen was noch geht
wo ich mein limit meine daten wurde ja
bereits in der app schon gesammelt das
heißt das habe ich vorhin schon nach
kontrolliere das steht alles jetzt drin
ich würde die zusätzlich noch in meine
motivation chart einfügen und ich bin
selbst überrascht dass ich das geschafft
der erste tag war für mich wirklich sehr
überraschend ich habe immer das gefühl
gehabt ich kenne mich in der sache schon
ein bisschen aus was zumindest die apps
betrifft vor allem bin ich überrascht
über meinen dass es so gut lief dass ich
danach noch puste hat und es gibt mir
hoffnung dass das ganze auch wirklich in
der zeit klappt wie ich mir das
vorgenommen haben
treffe ich mich um christoph um zu
rennen und kraftübungen zu machen
zu zweit macht einfach mehr spaß im
bezug auf sport läuft sehr sehr gut ich
habe angefangen damit meine zwei
kilometer und das auch wirklich gerade
so geschafft und jetzt mit meinem lauf
plan bin ich gestern ihre halb kilometer
schon gelaufen eine sehr gute pace und
jetzt fehlt einfach noch ein bisserl die
kraft die selbstmessung hier ist neben
dem fall sehr gut um mich zu motivieren
ich habe mein plan war eine app sagt man
war nicht zu laufen habe und vor allem
aber auch was ich zu laufen haben und
würde ich das jetzt nicht so mit messe
und nicht nach dem plan mache dann wäre
so wie keine steigerung und entwicklung
zu sehen
da hilft mir das wahnsinnig wo besser
der firma des clans ist kann ich sie
gerade zeigen und zwar müssen aus foto
machen für unser doch ist mir das nicht
vor und nach dem rennen extra dafür da
dass man sieht was man geleistet hat
ich finde dass die beste motivation also
genau notiz kann man noch hinzufügen
haben wir sagen war super dann liest vor
40 minuten 21
genau und hier auf dieser karte kann
strebe noch erkenne an welche stelle ich
jetzt zum beispiel weil es mein puls
gemessen hat im höchsten pulsbereich war
also wirklich kaum war eigentlich immer
wieso eigentlich hoch gegangen ist sieht
man wo ist und wo es runter war gegangen
ist wieder grün geworden und so czech
ich jetzt jedes rennen
man kann hier auch noch der fortschritt
anzeiger und dann sehe ich zum beispiel
hier wie viel kilometer bin ich laufe
und welche pace habe ich im schnitt und
wie viele kilometer insgesamt gelaufen
bin und mein jahresziel sind 150
kilometer und 18 uhr von mir schon
gelaufen
der fakt dass mir die app sagt was zu
tun habe finde ich genial
es liegt mir einfach was vor ich halte
mich daran und schlussendlich kann ich
mich darauf verlassen und macht es für
mich viel viel einfacher weil ich
einfach dem folgen was mir die app sagt
ich bin gerade aufgestanden und wurde
von meiner sleep cycle map geweckt wir
jetzt auch die letzten paar wochen wenn
ich sie abends stellen muss ich nur
sagen band spätestens auf machen möchte
und dann rechnet so eineinhalb stunden
zyklus wo es eben schaut wenn ich am
wachsen schon bin und fängt dann an mich
zu wecken also einbindung ganz normaler
wecker die app direkt zusätzlich nochmal
ein schlaf das heißt sie hört mir nachts
zu und kann dann durch diese
geräuschkulisse entscheiden die jetzt
meine schlafphase moment ist dann zeige
ich am besten mal was die app alles kann
ich nehme den schlafen heute nacht
dadurch die möglichkeit relativ lang zu
schlafen das hat sich auf die
schlafqualität ausgewirkt und ja die
herzfrequenz die wird eben morgens auch
gemessen und zwar geht dann hinten bei
der kameras licht an kamera licht und
die kamera können da mein herzschlag
nachmessen ich weiß nicht ob die app den
schlaf wirklich verbessern kann was mein
größter gewinn von der app ist dass ich
besser auf wache mich so dann auch
fitter fühlen und ich bin viel
aufmerksamer geworden in bezug auf
meinem schlaf
für mich ist mein pferd der einzige ort
an dem ich tatsächlich digital frei bin
und deswegen zählt für mich vor allem
zur erholung weil ich ja auch mal
abschalten kann
also ich bin vor zwei monaten vom pferd
gefallen war auch im krankenhaus aber es
ist für mich eher noch die motivation
noch mal zu überdenken was könnte ich
dann noch besser mache und wie können
nicht so situationen vermeiden
wir gehen hoch auf dem platz also er ist
landet ein drittel mehr schafe im moment
gerade vom bruder aus und wenig an der
sattel
aber es reicht noch nicht um freiheit
[Musik]
prima
ja in meinem motivation charts steht was
ich mir vorgenommen habe
und ja gleicht sich jetzt immer mehr ab
mit dem was ich erreicht habe meine
großen ziele pro kategorie war ja dass
sich beim sport fitter wehrt sich
tatsächlich geschafft dann zum thema
ernährung habe ich ja gesagt ich möchte
sechs kilo abnehmen
das ist in dreieinhalb wochen schon so
ein bisschen ein krasses ziel und heute
morgen habe ich mich gewogen und ich
habe es tatsächlich geschafft mein ziel
in der erholung mit den sieben stunden
schlaf im schnitt habe ich auch mit
heute oder gestern schon geschafft das
experiment selbst vermessen hat vor
allem dazu geführt dass ich immer
irgendwie leitfaden hatte was ich machen
soll machen muss und machen kann
kritik an der selbstmessung kann ich
eigentlich nur in dem punkt geben dass
man halt sehr sehr sehr viel von sich
preisgibt kann nicht so ganz
kontrollieren wo die daten landen und
vor allem bringt natürlich viel zeit vom
handy sind jetzt meine freunde gewöhnt
aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass jemand
der das auch gerne probieren würde dass
es auch schwierig sein kann weil viel
druck von außen kommt das fängt an mit
ja was trägt schüler was machst du da
die ganze zeit beschreibt das auf und
wiegt mit zu einer komischen waage was
ist wenn die daten irgendwie raus kommen
also ich glaube es ist eher das problem
dass diese unsicherheit von außen einen
dann selber unsicher macht es waren
meine groß das was ich erreichen wollte
und heute werde ich am run sein denn das
wird erst abgehalten wenn ich es
geschafft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es gibt noch viel zu tun
ich bin cool es gemacht haben
jetzt sind dreieinhalb wochen
[Musik]
ein bisschen die worte ich glaube dass
heute hat mir gezeigt dass sich das
lohnt das nur dadurch viel realistischer
reiche kann ich hab's mal alltag
eingebaut
und warum sollte ich das nicht machen
nicht wird gern ebenso ein bisschen
zeigen dass sich lohnt es anzufangen
und wenn es auch nur massen monat ist um
zu sagen okay ich hab das mal gemacht
das war so anstrengend gemacht